my name is Tom crampton I'm based out of
Hong Kong I run social media strategy
for Ogilvy and am a blogger and the
question of whether the political
problem is or economic problems are
going to be the biggest ones going ahead
I have to say I hope that it is economic
problems if the political problems are
the biggest problems facing east asia
these problems are so dangerous and
intractable that i hate to think what
they will be and i think from what we've
seen right now the state of the economic
crisis we might be seeing the green
shoots of recovery but certainly it's
nothing on the scale of what would
happen if we were had to have an
outbreak of conflict on the Korean
Peninsula or any of the other major
security issues or problem in the
spratlys which would have not just a
consequence among a couple of countries
but of global importance so I hope that
there are no economic a fewer economic
and fewer political problems but i think
that the danger is if they are political
ones